because Pokemon characters are for
whatever reason are like like actual
catnip to children so of course like I
open up my laptop and then I minute my
kid walks - she's just like that is
amazing like like please inject that
right into my eyeballs for the rapport
all time new in theaters this weekend
detective Pikachu the hustle and poms
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me it has been so long
looking for something to do this evening
the thought of staying in makes you
Snorlax mu - detective Pikachu comes out
this weekend in the modern the unfilled
world of rhyme city where humans and
pokémon coexist detective Harry Goodman
goes missing Harry's son Tim played by
justice myth teams up with Harry's
former partner the adorable yet witty
Pikachu voiced by Ryan Reynolds to solve
the mystery Harry faked his own death or
somebody else fake Harry's day before
Harry faked somebody else's dead that
last one doesn't work yo oh this movies
for you if you like the adorable yet
witty Ryan Reynolds you've been waiting
forever for a live-action Pokemon movie
or you're looking for someone to ash to
catch a movie with this weekend why are
women better suited to calm the men
because we're used to faking it because
no man will ever believe a woman is
smarter than he is is it valuable
$500,000 I like it cuz it's shiny all
throughout this weekend at the hustle a
super pro con artist played by Anne
Hathaway helps not so pro con artist
rebel Wilson fine-tuned her skills as
they team up to trick men reminds me of
college
[Music]
if you want to be like me you must be
trained before any situation she's ready
this comedy is a female lead remake of
the 1988 dirty rotten scoundrels a
remake itself of the 1964 bedtime story
never heard of it I wasn't alive yet sir
most minces dollars at a bow shot wasn't
expected this movies for you if you
enjoyed female empowerment do you find
the comedy and clash of Anne Hathaway
and rebel Wilson thoroughly entertaining
or con artists movies steal your breath
away brings you to Sun Springs
I'm just here to die there's not enough
erections around here as it is
and finally the silver-haired shimmy
their way onto the silver screen this
weekend and Tom's we want to start a
cheerleading Club who you be cheering
foam ourselves show us what you thought
[Music]
palms is a dance competition comedy
starring Diane Keaton Jacki Weaver Pam
Grier Rhea Perlman and more the story
follows the newest member of the
retirement community Martha who is
inspired to pick up cheerleading again
after years of regretting quitting the
first time around Martha and a group of
not so young friends find themselves
competing against high-flying youngsters
I've never had a grandma before and now
it's like I have eight you're one of us
now except with higher boobies this
movie is for you if you want a fun twist
on the classic dance-off movie
cheerleading is a thing you follow or
you want to feel alive again crew that
is your weekend ticket what will you see
and check back next week for some dog
movies
[Music]